on behalf of the Academy congratulations
to all the nominees and Oscar winners
your work is the reason this was an
amazing year in our industry your
artistry and skills are truly worthy of
the Academy's highest honor and as we
reflect upon your work of the past year
tonight is also a time to talk about the
future the Oscars celebrate the
storytellers who have the opportunity to
work in the powerful medium of film and
with that opportunity comes
responsibility our audiences are global
and rich in diversity
and every facet of our industry should
be as well
everyone in the Hollywood community has
a role to play in bringing about the
vital changes the industry needs so that
we can accurately reflect the world
today the Academy Board of Governors
recently took concrete action and sent a
message that inclusion only serves to
make us all stronger and it's important
that the members of the Academy and
everyone in this room help deliver that
message each of you is an ambassador who
can influence others in the industry
it's not enough to just listen and agree
we must take action while change is
often difficult it is necessary dr.
Martin Luther King once said the
ultimate measure of a man is not where
he stands in moments of comfort and
convenience but where he stands at times
of challenge and controversy I am
confident that together we can shape a
future of which all of us can be proud
thank you